على كل نتعرف اكثر على اهميه بخمه عبر
الخريطه التفاعليه مع صهيب العصا صهيب
نعود لنتحدث عن معارك في بخموت بعد ان
كانت تقريبا حسم الموضوع في تلك المنطقه
يعني ان صح التعبير لا يمكن القول سابقا
انه حسم الموضوع لان الصراع على باقي
يتجدد كل فتره وفتره لانها مهمه
استراتيجيه للطرفين سنتابع على التفاصيل
على الخريطه المشاهدين الكرام كما ذكرت
بين فينه واخرى يحسم الحديث عن بخمه ولكنه
على ارض الواقع لا يحسم عملياتيا نتحدث عن
باخم التي تقع في اقليم دنيتك وعن هذه
النقطه تحديدا عند الخط الفاصل بين
السيطره الروسيه والاوكرانيه في اقليم
دوله طبعا الخط الاحمر هو الخط الفاصل
للسيطره الروسيه الاوكرانيه في هذه
الاقاليم الاربعه كما نشاهد توقفت القوات
الروسيه عند هذه الحدود او الخط الفاصل
بين القوات
المتنازعه في هاتين المنطقتين تسيطر
القوات الروسيه بشكل كامل على اقليم
لوغانس تسيطر على حوالي 50 الى 60 من
اقليم دنيتك وتسيطر على حوالي 70% من
اقليمي
في المنطقه الجنوبيه كما نشاهد على
الخريطه هذه مناطق السيطره الروسيه بعد
500 يوم من القتال هذه الخريطه لم تتغير
كثيرا خلال الاسابيع او شهور القليله
الماضيه مع بعض التداخلات في السيطره بين
فيله واخرى بين القوات المتحاربه في هذه
المنطقه اذا تحدثنا اكثر عن باخمه في
المنطقه
الشماليه من اندونيسيك فنحن نتحدث عن هذه
المواقع هذه تقريبا خريطه السيطره الروسيه
في اقليم دنيتك كما شاهدنا قبل قليل هذه
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
وهذا هو الخط الفاصل بين القوات الروسيه
والقوات الاوكرانيين لما نتحدث عن او
لماذا نتحدث عن باخمه ان صح التعبير نتحدث
عن داخلها لا تبعد الا حوالي 30 كيلومتر
فقط عن
هي مركز عمليات الجيش الاوكراني وهي عاصمه
الاقليم اقليم دنيتك في الجهه التي تسيطر
عليها اوكرانيا لان مدينه دانيت عاصمه
الاقليم الاقليم ككل تسيطر عليه القوات
الروسيه بالتالي اتخذت القوات الاوكرانيه
مدينه اكراماتورسك عاصمه مؤقته اولا
وثانيا منطلق العمليات وبالتالي نحن نتحدث
كما ذكرت عن 30 كيلومتر فقط بين
كراماتورسك وباخ مت عن مركز العمليات
النقطه الثانيه في اهميه هي انها تشكل
خطوط الامداد او ملتقى الطرق الى
السوليدار والى اقليم لوغانست الذي تسيطر
عليه بشكل كامل القوات الروسيه كما نعلم
بطبيعه الحال وايضا تشكل باخمت الطرق نحو
المناطق الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه من
اقليم دنيت وعلى كل الحدود مع اقليم دني
وبالتالي اذا ما تحدثنا عن هذه المنطقه
فنحن نتحدث عن منطقه بالغه الاهميه بالغه
الاستراتيجيه للطرفين لان كلا الطرفين
يحاولان السيطره عليها القوات الاوكرانيه
تحاول السيطره على باقي حتى تتقدم اكثر
وبالتالي تكسر الحواجز في المنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه من اقليم دنيات القوات
الروسيه تحاول السيطره او تحاول تثبيت
اقدامها في باغمه حتى تتمكن من الهجوم
مستقبلا على كراماتورسكو وبالتالي السيطره
واكمال السيطره على المناطق اشعر الشماليه
الغربيه من اقليم جونسون لذلك هي باخموت
مهمه استراتيجيا لكلا الطرفين ولذلك
الصراع دائما محتدم ومستدام حتى هذه
اللحظه بعد 500 يوم على باخمه هكذا نتحدث
عن باقي
الاستراتيجيه رغم بعدها الكبيره عن
العاصمه 500 او 600 كم عن العاصمه ولكن
تبقى ضخمه بالغه الاهميه الان اي سقوط
لباك في هذه احد من الطرفين سيعني لاحقا
تقدما لاحد من الطرفين باتجاه مناطق سيطره
الطرف